[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तू जो वेलकम तू
फ्री कैप्सूल कोर्स
कंफर्म कर दीजिए
चाट में बता दीजिएगा
ओके थैंक यू प्रिंस
तो एक बार यह बताइए की लास्ट क्लास में जो
भी मैंने करवाया अभी तक डेट और तक जिसने
जितना कर किया है सबको समझ में आया किसी
को डाउट है
ओके तो आज का मैं टॉपिक रहेगा जो बेसिकली
ट्री
बोलते हैं दूसरा टॉपिक रहेगा लॉकेट कमांड
मैं ट्राई करता हूं दोनों डिलीवर कर दूंगा
तो भीम कमांड
भीम जो कमांड है बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड है वो हर एक को लाइनेक्स
एडमिन को है कोई भी लिरिक्स यूजर हो उसको
पता ही होना चाहिए क्योंकि बाय डिफॉल्टर
आपकी किसी भी लिमिट मशीन में भी मेडिटरा
है जिसको बोलते हैं वो देखने को मिलता है
ही मिलता है
वो आपको देखने को मिलेगा अगर आप उसके साथ
फैमिलियर नहीं हो और सो दादा की आप क्या
कर रहे हो अपने अटैक कर रहे हो किसी भी
मशीन को और आपको क्या आएगी उसके अलावा वे
आई की एडिटर के अलावा कोई टूल मिला नहीं
और आपको उसे करना नहीं आता तो आपके साथ
चैलेंज फेस हो सकते हैं और आपको अगर वो
उसे करना है तो आप अच्छा खास मौका हो सकते
हो अगर वहां पर आपको
मिल जाता है तो
फनी पिंस डेट हो गया
तो प्लीज
स्टार्ट करेंगे तो प्लीज टाइम से चीज
के बड़े में जो हम सीखने वाले हैं जो
टॉपिक हमारा रहेगा
यह एडिटर का युद्ध हम फाइल को ओपन करने के
लिए उसको एडिट करने के लिए या फिर नई फाइल
को क्रिएट करने के लिए उसे करते हैं
उसके कुछ ऑपरेटिंग मोड्स होते हैं बेसिकली
उसके बहुत सारे ऑपरेटिंग मोड है लेकिन
बेसिकली उसके जो कर ऑपरेटिंग मोड्स हैं
वह आपको मैं भी बताने जा रहा हूं कौन-कौन
से कर ऑपरेटर है
जिसको हम बोलते हैं
इस के बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो डाटा
कमांड मोड
के थ्रू किसी भी फाइल को क्रिएट करोगे या
ओपन करोगे
ईटीसी
ओके डेफिनेशन
ओके और
अदर
मोर
परिसर ऑपरेशंस
ओके
थोड़ा पता चल जाएगा
तो मैं बताऊंगा की अब हम किस मोड में ए
गया कम कर रहे हैं की इस मोड में ए गया कम
कर रहे हैं तो आपको पता चल जाएगा ठीक होता
है आपका
कम क्या है
मैं भी
सिलेक्टेड
पर टेक्स्ट
मैनिपुलेशन
करते हैं
हाईलाइट
तो बेसिकली ये कर मोड थे अब मैं क्या करता
हूं की वन बाय वन बाय आपको क्या समझता हूं
की जो ये कम है कैसे कम करता है बम जो
कमांड है
तो जो वे आई एडिटर है देखो जब भी हम किसी
फाइल ओपन करते हैं किसी भी फाइल को अपडेट
करते हैं तो वे आई एडिटर बाय डिफॉल्ट
कमांड मोड में अपन होता है हम आपको पता है
बाय डिफॉल क्या करता है कमांड होता है
एग्जांपल में क्या करता हूं भीम करता हूं
और मैंने क्या कर दिया एक फाइल ओपन
www.ext के नाम से फाइल ओपन
है ये आपका क्या है कमांड मोड है अगर मुझे
इसके अंदर
कुछ भी एड करना है कोई भी राइट ऑपरेशन
करना है पर एग्जांपल मुझे इसके अंदर कुछ
भी डाटा लिखना है या कुछ
भी कम करना है न्यू फाइल है इसके अंदर
मुझे क्या राइट करना है तो मुझे क्या करना
होगा इसके अंदर इसके लिए मुझे इंसर्ट मोड
में जाना होगा इसके लिए मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा इंसर्ट मोड में जाना होगा और
इनसाइड बाल में कैसे जाते हैं
आप क्या करोगे आप अपनी मशीन में प्रेस
करोगे सिंपली प्रेस आई सिंपली आई विदाउट
कैप्स लॉक ऑन सिंपली जैसे मैंने आई प्रेस
किया अब देखो नीचे आप नीचे देखना ध्यान से
बिल्कुल यहां पर क्या हो गया आपको देख रहा
होगा हाईलाइट में इंस्टेंट ए गया मतलब आप
क्या कर सकते हो इसमें राइटिंग कम कर सकते
हो लिख सकते जैसे
है
लाइनेक्स
यूजर और
अलसो और
डिलीवर
जो
योर पर्सनल
बेनिफिट्स
बेनिफिट
क्या किया
ओके देखो स्टार्टिंग में जो सबसे पहले
तू को तू कमांडो
क्या कहना पड़ेगा सिंपली आपको क्या करना
प्रेस शिफ्ट के साथ कॉलर चिप के साथ कॉलर
अब जैसे शिव के साथ आप कोलोन करोगे यहां
पे ये हाईलाइट हो गया नीचे कॉर्नर में मैं
लेफ्ट कॉर्नर में और उसके बाद आपको क्या
लिखना है
उसके बाद आपको करना है राइट क्योंकि आपने
राइट एन परसों किया है दें आपको कब
क्योंकि मतलब
मैंने क्या कर दिया इसके अंदर वो डाटा एड
कर दिया अगर मैं इनफॉरमेशन
अब ये हां कैसे किया था
सिंपली प्रेस किया उसके बाद वीट यहां से
मुझे क्या करनी है
से राइट और क्यूट
और
यूआईटी ओके
सर हा के ऊपर हा के ऊपर मेरा क्या है
कर्सर है आपको दिखाई दे रहा हूं इधर जो है
व्हाइट कलर में हाईलाइट हो रहा था अब मुझे
क्या करना भारत
हम चाहे अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की
अगर मैं अपने कस्टमर को मुंह करवाना चाहता
हूं तो सिंपली क्या करूंगा वन बाय वन बाय
मैं अपने जो अरा है अप डॉ अरा है लेफ्ट
राइट अरा उससे कैसा था मैं प्रेस करता
रहूंगा अब एक तो तरीका ये है और ये अगर
आपकी फाइल बहुत ज्यादा बढ़िया तो आपको
क्या करना है प्रॉब्लम होगी तरीके में
दूसरा एक और तरीका होता है पर एग्जांपल
मुझे क्या करना है अपने पर्सनल को सीधा
डायरेक्ट ली और में मूव करवाना है क्या
करना है मुझे और में मूव करवाना है और
वहां से मुझे राइटिंग करनी है पर एग्जांपल
मुझे यहां पर हैक कर जा भाई ये है मुझे
यहां से क्या करना है रेड डॉ करना है तो
अब यहां करना है तो मैं कैसे करूंगा तो
मेरा कर्सर अभी इधर है स्टार्टिंग मैच के
ऊपर तो सिंपली आपको क्या करना है सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है शिफ्ट के साथ प्रेस
करना है शिव के साथ प्रेस है या जिसे
बोलते हम कैपिटल है
देखो ये मेरा कासल डायरेक्टली लास्ट में ए
गया आगे मैं फिर से दिखता हूं आपको फिर से
आपको बता देता हूं एक बार और एक और नोटिस
चीज नोटिस करना फिर जैसे ही आप क्या करते
हो शिव के साथ ए प्रेस करते हो शिफ्ट के
साथ ये प्रेस करते हो तो आपका इंसर्ट मोड
में चला जाता है क्योंकि आप क्या कर रहे
हो की आपको जो हेक्टर है इसके बाद क्या
करना कोई कंटेंट एड करना है और वहां पर
डायरेक्ट लाने के लिए आपको क्या शिफ्ट के
साथ ए प्रेस करोगे तो लास्ट लाइन में चले
जो उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो
दें इंसर्ट मोड में हो गया उसके बाद
लास्ट ऑफ लाइन
क्या कर रहा हूं आप मुझे क्या करना है की
मेरा कर्सर यहां पर है मेरा कसार कहां पर
है हा के ऊपर स्टार्टिंग में है अब मेरा
आगे के ऊपर करसन है तो मुझे क्या करना है
की मैं यही से लिखना चाहता हूं
स्टार्टिंग से ही बट क्या की आप आपको
लिखने की जरूर सिंपली क्या करोगे डायरेक्ट
इंसर्ट मोड में जाना है तो आप पैसे तो
आईबी प्रेस करोगे तो आप इधर लिखना स्टार्ट
कर डॉग
जैसे मैं अब कुछ भी इसके बीच में क्या कर
सकता हूं एड कर सकता हूं क्या आपको देखने
को मिल रहा होगा
कहां पर था एचपी था और मैं फिर से मोड
देता हूं हा के हा के ऊपर मैं कर सकता अब
मुझे क्या किया जैसे मैंने ए प्रेस किया
तो यहां पर आएगी अभी मैं कर्सर ए गया और
हा के आगे से मैं क्या कर सकता हूं लिखना
शुरू कर सकता हूं हा के बाद मैं सो सकता
था की हा का आगे मुझे क्या लिखा था हेलो
हेलो मिस्टर आई मुझे नहीं लिखना ओके तो ये
है हेलो अब मैंने ये कर दिया तो ये चीज है
आपको बता देता हूं मैंने क्या क्या कम
किया मैंने क्या किया एक तो प्रेस किया
और ऑफलाइन
अवर टेक्स्ट फ्रॉम डी कर्सर
जहां पर मेरा कर्सर था और ऑफ डी लाइन
का प्रनंसीएशन
आपको याद रहे इसलिए मैं आपके लिए थोड़ी सी
मेहनत कर रहा हूं नोट्स बनाने वाली
एडरवाइज क्या है सिंपली मैं अगर बता देता
आपको खुद से ही बनाने पढ़ेंगे तो यह सिर्फ
नोट्स बना लीजिए तो आपको पता चल गया अब
मुझे क्या करना है अब मैं क्या करता हूं
अगर मैं करंट जो कर्सर है उससे पहले से
लिखना स्टार्ट करना चाहता हूं करंट परसों
अभी मैंने क्या किया था जब हा के बाद
स्टार्ट किया था मैं इससे पहले लिखना
चाहता हूं इससे पहले मैं क्या कहना चाहता
हूं
है हेलो
हेलो ठीक है तो अभी जो सिंपली आई प्रेस कर
रहा था वह आपको पता ही है
अब पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या कहा था अगर मैं
जी पर्टिकुलर लाइन में मैं कर्सर है मेरा
कौन सी लाइन है मेरी हेलो वाली लाइन है जो
कसूर है मेरा ये वाली लाइन में जहां पर
हेलो है अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की मैं
इससे अगली लाइन में क्या कहना चाहता हूं
अपना टेक्स्ट इंटर करना चाहता हूं अपनी
लाइफ में क्या करना था टेक्स्ट इंटर करना
चाहता हूं वो कैसे करूंगा या तो सिंपली या
क्या करोगे आप प्रेस करोगे
तो सिंपली जैसे स्पेस हो गया तो इसने क्या
कर दिया एक इसके नीचे न्यू लाइन एम्टी
लाइन कनेक्ट कर दिया और वहां पर क्या करना
है आपको अपना टेक्स्ट लिख सकते हो उसके
बाद मैं क्या लेना चाहता हूं
आई हैव
मैं इसके अंदर एड करना चाहता हूं हेलो
वर्ल्ड
करके उसके अंदर कुछ टैक्स एड करना चाहता
था उसके लिए आपको क्या करना है शिफ्ट के
साथ ओ प्रेस करना पड़ेगा शिफ्ट के साथ अप
प्रेस करते ही एक मिनट आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा शिफ्ट के साथ क्या करना फ्रेश हो
बड़े
करूंगा
एड कर देता है आपके राइट डॉ करने के लिए
अगर जहां पर आपको कर्सर है अगर उसके ऊपर
एक लाइन एड करना चाहता हूं वहां पर क्या
करना पड़ेगा आपको एक आपको सिर्फ प्लस ओ एड
करना होगा तो वहां पर मैं लिख सकता हूं
इसके अंदर में क्या लिख सकता हूं कुछ भी
कुछ भी एड कर दिया ओके
इसमें टाइम काफी ग रहा है
इसका क्या मतलब है ये आप अपने शब्द में
लिख लेना नेक्स्ट में ने बताया
शिफ्ट प्लस में ओ लेकिन ये क्या सारे कम
किसमे कर रहा है कमांड मोड में है सारे के
सारे कब अभी तक जैसे की ये शिफ्ट प्लस ए
प्लस ए प्लस ओ चिप प्लस
ये साड़ी चीज कम करेंगे
की क्यूट कैसे करना है ये कैसे करना है
आपको बताता है तो अब हम सीखने हैं की जो
एडिटर है मैं हम कैसे रिप्लेस और डिलीट कर
सकते हैं
अभी क्या किया कमांड मोड में और मुझे जान
की जरूर नहीं है तो जी भी करैक्टर को हम
डिलीट करना चाहते हैं
जो फालतू मैंने एड किया है मैंने यहां पर
ले चला गया ये रहा ये ये ऊपर मैंने कर्सर
है अब मैं इस करैक्टर को डिलीट करना चाहता
हूं तो मैं क्या करूंगा सिंपली क्या
करूंगा प्रेस एक्स नॉर्मल एक्स सिंपली
प्रेस एक्स देखो जैसे प्रेस किया वो कर्सर
जो भी जिसके ऊपर कर सा था क्वेश्चन वाला
करैक्टर डिलीट हो रहा है फिर से बेस्ट
एक्स इसे आई के ऊपर से ले गया प्रेस एक्स
के के ऊपर कैसे लगेगा बेस्ट एक्स तो इसमें
क्या कर दिया
उसे करैक्टर को डिलीट कर दिया जिसके ऊपर
कर्सर था अगर हम चाहते हैं की कर्सर से
पहले
पहले का करैक्टर डिलीट हो जाए तो हम कैसे
करेंगे
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है
उसको छोड़ के उससे पहले वाला करैक्टर क्या
हो रहा है डिलीट हो रहा है
इसने डिलीट कर दिया अब एक और चीज है अगर
आपको उंडू करना है उंडू मतलब आपको पता
होना चाहिए जैसा पहले था अंडो करने के लिए
आपको सिंपली क्या प्रेस करोगे
तो आपको पता चल गया होगा मैं एक और चीज
बताता हूं यार मैंने क्या किया
एक्स बताया इसका क्या मतलब आप लिख लीजिए
अपने भाषा में
नॉर्मल
सेक्स मतलब
प्रेस और जो भी कीवर्ड उसके साथ एड करना
चाहते हो उसे करैक्टर की जगह वो आप लिख
सकते हो अब मैंने डॉलर कर दिया अब यह क्या
एड हो गया और देखो इंस्टेंट मोड में जान
की जरूर भी नहीं पड़ी फिर से अगर मैं
दिखता हूं पर एग्जांपल मैं हेलो
[संगीत]
बेनिफिट्स ओके
तो मैं क्या करूं
मुझे क्या करना है अगर मुझे
कट और पेस्ट करना है मतलब इसका जो है यह
जहां पर
पेस कर देना जैसे यहां पर कर्सर है तो यह
ऐसा ही बन जाएगा
और पेस्ट के लिए सिंपली प्रेस करना है
क्या था अंडो फिर से कर देता हूं
उसके बाद फिर क्या कर दिया उसको पेस्ट कर
दिया कट और पेस्ट तो मैंने क्या बताया अभी
जो चीज बताई मैंने एक ये बताई आपको
कम क्या है
रिप्लेस रिप्लेस करने का कम है और मैं जो
बताया उसके बाद क्या बताएं मैंने अगर कट
और पेस करना तो आपके करना है प्रेस
एक्स और पी एक साथ में
तो यह करेगा
उसे लाइन को कट करना
चाहता हूं कट करना चाहता हूं अगर मैं इसको
कट करना चाहता हूं पुरी लाइन को तो सिंपली
तू टाइम्स प्रेस कर दूंगा तू टाइम्स क्या
प्रेस करूंगा डीडी लो ये लाइन कट होगी और
मुझे जहां पर इसको पेस्ट करना है जहां पर
पेस्ट करना है पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना
है यहां पर पेस्ट करना है ये यहां पर
बेनिफिट्स के बाद तो सिंपली मैं यहां पर
ले गया और सिंपली प्रेस पी सिंपली प्रेस
p4 पेस्ट और कर दिया पेस्ट अब इसमें क्या
कहते हैं आप इसको पेस्ट कर दिया जैसे मुझे
क्या करना है फिर से वैसे करना है ये आई
एम डिलीवरिंग दिस ट्रेनिंग
फोर्थ टेस्ट रिपोर्ट पेस्ट ओके
पेस्ट करना पड़ेगा
कॉपी और पेस्ट ऐसे करते हैं अगर आपको एक
कम करना है पर एग्जांपल आपको इन दोनों
लाइन को एक साथ क्या करना है कट करना है
पर एग्जांपल इन दोनों को आपका क्या करना
है कट करना है एक साथ तो क्या करोगे जहां
पर कर्सर है एक तो वो लाइन है दूसरी आप
क्या कहना चाहते हैं उसके नीचे वाले का
लाइन क्योंकि जहां पर कर्स है उसके बाद आप
पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या है दो लाइनें का
तो करना तो मैं सिंपली प्रेस करूंगा
प्रेस किया जो तू है नंबर है उसके बाद दी
और दी इसने क्या किया जहां पर आपका कर्सर
है एक उसे लाइन को कट किया साथ में तू
लिखा था उससे नीचे वाले एक लाइन को इसने
क्या कर दिया कट कर दिया फिर से मैं अंदर
कर देता हूं मैंने प्रेस किया क्या
देता हूं तो मैंने अभी क्या बताया आपको
कोई एग्जांपल अगर आप दो लाइन में कट करना
है तो जैसे आपको सिंपली पहले प्रेस
तू टाइम्स
करने का कम आएगा
तू लाइंस
करना है
अगर आपको मूव करना है अगर आपको मुंह करना
है
डायरेक्शन में शब्द बाय शब्द
बाय जंप करना पर एग्जांपल मैं अभी क्या कर
रहा हूं अभी तो मैं क्या करूं हेलो उसके
बाद वन करैक्टर मूव कर रहा हूं लेकिन अगर
मुंह करना है मुझे शब्द बाय शब्द जंप करना
है उसके लिए मुझे सिंपली क्या करना है
प्रेस ब्लू देखो अब मैं नेक्स्ट शब्द
बाय शब्द में क्या कर रहा हूं मूव कर रहा
हूं ब्लू प्रेस करने से फोटो डायरेक्शन
में अगर आपको बैकवर्ड डायरेक्शन में शब्द
बाय शब्द मूव करना तो सिंपली प्रेस करना
है बी सिंपली प्रेस बी देखो शब्द भाई शब्द
आप क्या करो कर पाओगे मुंह कर पाओगे अगर
आपको
क्या करना पर आपको डिलीट ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म
करना है अगर आपको क्या करना है किसी शब्द
को डिलीट करना पड़ेगा एग्जांपल मैंने इसको
अगर मैंने शब्द को डिलीट करना है तो आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है
डिलीट करने के लिए मैंने दी का मतलब डिलीट
w4 वर्ल्ड मैं इसको डिलीट कर दिया अगर
मुझे क्या करना है 2 शब्द को डिलीट करना
है पर एग्जांपल नीचे वाले जो दो शब्द हैं
तुम्हारे डिलीट करना है
दो बार स्टूडेंट
बन जाएगा
तीन शब्द को डिलीट करना
डिलीट कर दिया तो मैंने क्या बताया आपको
एक तो अभी बताया मैंने सिंपली अगर मूव
करना है अगर आपको क्या करना है
तो हम सिंपली प्रेस करेंगे
कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल भी और बैकवर्ड डायरेक्शन तो मुझे
क्या करना है बैकवर्ड डायरेक्शन
तो हम कैसे करेंगे
प्रेस
बी सी करेंगे प्रेस
इसका मतलब दो शब्द को मैं डिलीट करना
चाहता हूं एक साथ अगर मैंने क्या किया
प्रेस 3 डूप्स इसका मतलब क्या है 3 शब्द
को एक साथ में क्या करवा रहा हूं डिलीट
करवा रहा हूं और एक्टिव बताता हूं अगर
आपको क्या करना है अभी क्या-क्या आप
ऑलरेडी इसमें एस्केप मोड में हो अगर आपको
सिंपली ओनली इस मशीन से एग्जिट करना है
लेकिन आपको ओनली से करना है ओनली कंट्रोल
एस वाला कम करना है ओनली राइट करना है तो
आपको कहना शिफ्ट के साथ ओलिंप प्रेस करना
है जो आपको लेफ्ट कॉर्नर में आपको देखने
को मिलेगा उसके बाद सिंपली वीट इंटर तो
इसने क्या कर दिया इसको से कर दिया अगर आप
विदाउट से क्या करना चाहते हो फिट करना
चाहते हो वो भी कर सकते हैं लेकिन उससे
पहले मैं आपको क्या दिखाना चाहता हूं अगर
हां अगर आपको विदाउट करना तो सिंपली
ये देखो विदाउट वेट कर पाओगे अगर आपको
फोर्सफुल लिक्विड करना है तो सिंपली के और
यह एस्केलेशन लिक्विड करेगा
अब आपको क्या करना है फाइल का नाम क्या है
टेस्ट bhim.tiex है अब मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं जब मैंने अपने फाइल में बहुत सा
डाटा राइट डॉ कर लिया मैं चाहता हूं की अब
मेरा मां हुआ की मैं इसका नाम चेंज करना
चाहता हूं क्या करूंगा ऐसा समझना की मैं
इसको मूव करूंगा नहीं यही से कर सकते हो
कैसे कर सकते हो सिंपली प्रेस उसके बाद
क्या डब्लू करते हैं जब राइट करते हो तो
स्पेस देकर फाइल का नाम दे सकते हो पर
एग्जांपल मैं नाम रख देता हूं
चेंज कर दिया अगर मैं फिट करके दिखता हूं
आपको फिट करके दिखता हूं तो अगर मैं
आपको दिखता हूं
ल एस
यहां देखने को मिलेगा
ओके ओके मॉडिफाइड मॉडिफाइड लुक एट
मॉडिफाइड
लोकेशन
होता है की आप ये शिफ्ट वाला झंझट में
नहीं पढ़ना चाहते तो डायरेक्टली आप क्या
कर सकते हो सेवन एग्जिट कर सकते हो तो
कैसे करोगे सिंपली प्रेस करोगे सिंपली
प्रेस
करोगे
इसका मतलब क्या है कलम ब्लू का मतलब क्या
होता है ये आपको पता होगा अभी मैंने बता
दिया उसके बाद अगर ऑनलाइन
क्यों इसका मतलब क्या है यह भी मैंने आपको
बताया अभी
लिख लेना उसके बाद अगर आपको क्या करना
मैंने क्या बताया था
बहन उसके बाद मैंने बताया आपको अभी
प्रेस करना है
सर्चिंग करनी है तो कैसे करोगे
ओके
आप ऐसे सर्च करोगे नेक्स्ट
जो केवल उसने सर्च किया जहां भी फाइल में
उसके ऊपर अगर जाना है तो सिंपली प्रेस
करना एन सिंपली प्रेस करना है आपको एन
सिंपली प्रेस करना क्या करना है आपको एन
प्रेस करना है अगर आपको बॉटम तू टॉप सर्च
करना है अगर आपको बॉटम टॉप सर्च करना है
तो सिंपली आप क्या करोगे क्वेश्चन मार्क
उसके बाद क्या लिखोगे जो मैं लिखा जो ये
बॉटम तू टॉप सर्च करेगा अगर इसका जो
नेक्स्ट जो गैस के अवार्ड है उसके ऊपर
ज्यादा सिंपली प्रेस और पे भी मैंने आपको
बता दिया
नाम
और सचिन
तू तो आप क्या करोगे सर्च करोगे
किसी भी दूसरी फाइल का आउटपुट या किसी और
कमांड का जो आउटपुट है मैं इसके अंदर से
करना चाहता हूं आगे आईटी इसे कैसे करोगे
आप सिंपली करोगे तो आप क्या करोगे
यह क्या को करोगे रीड डायरेक्ट करोगे इसके
अंदर एड करोगे ऐसे करोगे दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या
है आप किसी भी कमांड का आउटपुट अगर
डायरेक्टली इसके अंदर क्या-क्या चाहते हो
से करना चाहते हैं तो वो भी कर सकते हो
उसके लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा पहले
प्रेस करना पड़ेगा
मैं एक कमांड होते हैं हमारे पास ल एस बी
ल के कमांड होती है
तो उसका जो आउटपुट था एलएसबीएल का कमांड
का ये यहां पर इसको आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है एलएसबीएल के कमांड का आउटपुट आपको यहां
पर देखने को मिल रहा है अगर आप क्या करना
चाहते हैं किसी एक फाइल है जहां पे इस
फाइल को अपने ओपन किया हुआ है ये तो आपको
पता चल गया एलएसबीएल के कमांड अगर आपको
फिर से अगर मैं दिखाऊं आपको करके शिफ्ट के
साथ उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको आर उसे
करना है स्पेस करना है एस्केलेशन मार जैसे
मुझे अब दूसरी कौन सी कमांड थी मेरी एक और
कमांड है जिसका से कर सकता हूं पर
एग्जांपल आपको पता हूं तो
मौसी को मानना एलएस आईफोन
यह था हमारा कौन सा विम कमांड के बड़े में
अगर मैं चाहूं तो आपको उसके बड़े में बता
सकता हूं लेकिन यह आपके लिए एन है
क्योंकि इसके बड़े में जितना पढ़ सकते हो
बहुत ज्यादा पढ़ने के लिए क्योंकि बहुत
ज्यादा बड़ी कमांड है आप चाहे तो अगले 1/2
घंटे भी इसके ऊपर स्टैंड कर सकते हैं तो
आगे ए बिगनर आपके लिए इतना काफी है
क्योंकि एडरवाइज आप बर हो जाओगे क्योंकि
इतने साड़ी चीज क्योंकि विजुअल मोड है हां
विजुअल मोड के बड़े में बता देता हूं की
वो कैसे कम करता है अगर आपको हाईलाइट का
कम करना है ना जैसे की मैं बता रहा था अगर
किसी भी शब्द को आपको हाईलाइट करना है तो
कैसे करोगे तो आप क्या करना चाहते हो
आप
मोड में जान के लिए आप सिंपली क्या करो
पहले प्रेस करोगे बी आपने क्या रिक्वेस्ट
किया तो नीचे ए गया
करैक्टर बाई करैक्टर सिलेक्ट करना चाहते
हो तो आप क्या करोगे सिंपली कीबोर्ड से
आगे बाढ़ रहे हो देखो आपका
देखो ये साड़ी अरा अप डॉ लेफ्ट राइट वाले
की की है ना उसके थ्रू आप क्या विजुअल मोड
में जाके इसको हाईलाइट करते जो खुद ही
सिलेक्ट करते जा रहे हो मैं कुछ नहीं कर
रहा मैंने सिंपली किया था मैंने कर सका
मैंने जहां पर मैं फोर के अंदर जीपी कर
सकता था उसके बाद मैंने क्या है मैं फिर
एचसीएफ मॉडल राहत हूं पर एग्जांपल
ये म्यूजिक वाली जो लाइन है इसको सिलेक्ट
करना चाहता हूं तो सिंपली मा जाऊंगा
विजिबल मोड और मैं इसको
प्रेस करता हूं कंटिन्यू प्रेस किया तो
आगे बाढ़ गया देखो
तो अब मुझे क्या माउस की बजाई क्योंकि कई
जगह को पता चला है की आपको माउस एक्सेस
नहीं मिल रहा तो आप क्या कीबोर्ड से सर कम
करना पड़ेगा तो कीबोर्ड से भी आप से
सिलेक्शन वाला कम कर सकते हैं अगर आप
ब्लॉक वॉइस सिलेक्ट करना चाहते हैं ब्लॉक
वाइस इन डी सेंस कैसे ब्लॉक वाइस आप
सिलेक्ट करना चाहते हैं जैसे ये वो लोग
ऐसे ऐसे होता है बोलो में ब्लॉक वाइस ऐसे
ये एक ब्लॉक है फिर ये ब्लॉक है फिर अगर
आप ऐसे सिलेक्शन करना चाहते हो की की भाई
की की बजे तो सिंपली आप क्या करोगे जैसे
मेरा यहां पे कर्सर है वो एग्जांपल मेरा
यहां पर है तो मैंने क्या किया कंट्रोल भी
कंट्रोल भी प्रेस करते हैं क्या है विजुअल
ब्लॉक ए गया यहां पे लिखा विजुअल ब्लॉक तो
कैसे ओके ठीक है अब ये पूरा ब्लॉक हो
जाएगा ऐसे ऐसे मैंने ऐसे किया देखो ये
ओनली इसी ब्लॉक को सिलेक्ट करता जाएगा
ओनली देखो ओनली उससे पहले क्या हो रहा था
मैं करैक्टर में करैक्टर ऊपर जाता तो पुरी
लाइन को सिलेक्ट कर लेट है जहां पर मैंने
प्रेजेंट करके लेकिन अब ये क्या ब्लॉक हो
जाएगा यहां पे किया मैंने ये हो गया इतना
मैं एक साथ क्या है तो दिस इसे डी
सिलेक्शन ब्लॉक वाइस तो ये आपको पता चल
गया होगा
अगर आपको क्या है लाइन बाय लाइन करना था
तो भी कर सकते थे लेकिन अभी एक बार एस्केप
मॉडल आता हूं तो आपको क्या करना है सिंपली
शिफ्ट के साथ वी प्रेस करना है तो लाइन
देखो 1 2 3 4 ऐसे लाइन बाय लाइन अब ये
सिलेक्शन लाइन बाय लाइन लाइक करेगा तो मैं
आपको बता दिया अगर आपको विजुअल विजुअल मोड
में जाना था आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
प्रेस वे करना है जब आप प्रेस भी करोगे तो
आप चले जाओगे विजिबल मोड में और जहां आप
सिलेक्शन करोगे आप चले जाओगे विजुअल मोड
में और वहां पर क्या है सिलेक्शन किया
जाएगा
भाई इलेक्शन
ब्लॉक के अंदर
सिलेक्शन
ब्लॉक
स्विफ्ट प्लस बी लेकिन ध्यान रखना की अब
कमांड मोड में होना चाहिए ये तीनों कम
करते वक्त आप कमांड मोड में होना चाहिए
कम नहीं करेगा अब क्या है आपको कमांड मॉडल
में होना पड़ेगा तो इसके लिए क्या करोगे
ये कौन सा ये भी विजुअल विजुअल लाइन जाएगा
विजुअल लाइन मोड तो अब लाइन बाय लेंस
सिलेक्ट करोगे इसमें लाइन बाय लाइन
बाय लाइन सिलेक्शन यह थी हमारी वे एडिट पे
कमांड विम कमांड के बड़े में आपको देखने
को मिला होगा तो एक बार मुझे चाट में
कंफर्म कर दीजिए जितने भी लोग प्रेजेंट
हैं एक या दो तीन क्या आप लोगों को समझ
में आया नहीं आया
देखो यह ऐसी कमांड है इसके बड़े में आपको
क्या एक चित बना के रखती होगी या एक आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा अपने पास इसके एक नोट्स
बना के रखना ही होंगे
और जैसे अब डेली बेसिस को उसे करोगे तो
फैमिली हो जाओगे
एडिटर को फॉलो करो और कंटिन्यू कुछ भी आप
एडिटिंग करना है राइटिंग करना है कुछ भी
कम करना आप इसी के अंदर करो तो शो डेट की
आपको उसकी आदत पद जाए और धीरे-धीरे आपको
इसकी जो की शब्द हैं इसका क्या मतलब है
कैसे सिलेक्शन करना है कैसे क्या करना है
कट कॉपी पेस्ट रिप्लेस कैसे करना आउटपुट
कैसे एड करना है ये साड़ी चीज सब फैमिली
हो जाए तो आप कभी नहीं बोलोगे
ओके थैंक यू प्लीज लक्ष्मी नारायण थैंक यू
तो
वैसे हमारा टाइम ही हो गया
लॉकेट कमांड
तो कल कर लेंगे
तो बताइए
की प्रिंस लक्ष्मी
करें
11 12 13 14 15 4 डेज की क्लास में आपका
जितना मैं टारगेट सिलेक्ट किया था वह आपका
हो जाएगा नो इशू क्योंकि थोड़ा आपको मैं
एक चीज आपको बता देता हूं क्या-क्या
बताऊंगा एक आपको इसके बड़े में बता दूंगा
की थोड़ा बहुत नेटवर्क कैसे आप सिलेक्शन
करते हैं नेटवर्क कमांड के थ्रू आप कैसे
हैं आप नेटवर्क सेटिंग करते हो कमांड के
थ्रू कमांड लाइन के थ्रू दूसरा अगर हम
आपको बताऊंगा की ये
रिपोजिटरी के बड़े में की कैसे आपको कमांड
उसे करते हो कोई भी पैकेज आपको डाउनलोड
करना है इंस्टॉल करना है अनइनस्टॉल करना
है उसके बड़े में बताऊंगा सर्च करना है एक
को बताएंगे दूसरा टॉपिक तीसरा थोड़ा बहुत
और बैक गया कुछ स्पेशल अगर आपको थोड़ी सी
सर्चिंग और फास्ट करनी है
ओके अगर आपको सर्चिंग थोड़ी सी फास्ट और
करनी है तो वह भी हम कर सकते हैं की थोड़ा
सा ज्यादा अच्छे तरीके से अच्छे वो भी कुछ
कमांड्स है उसके बड़े में बात करेंगे और
थोड़ी एक हिस्ट्री कमांड है
तो यह सब चीज हम बताएंगे तो ये बता देता
आपका मतलब एक फंडामेंटल आपका क्लियर हो
जाएगा फंडामेंटल नॉलेज
एडॉप्शन इस ओपन पर एवरीवन
लक्ष्मी
वैसे लोग फालतू लोग मुझे लगता हैं
आईएफ यू आर न्यू तो कम कीजिए हमने जब
सीरियस स्टार्ट करने से पहले हमने क्या
किया था की इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस बताया था
तो आप जाइए वहां से इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस
मिल जाएगा और आप वहां से क्या फॉलो करके
पूरे स्टेप बाय स्टेप अपनी मशीन में आप
क्या कर सकते हैं इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो और
किसी भी इंस्टॉल करने के लिए इस टाइप होते
हैं नोट ओनली पर काली एवं पर सेंट आस परत
आस
उबंटू स्टेप सिमिलर होते हैं थोड़े बहुत
चीज रहती हैं यस नो यस नो वो आप समझ जाते
हो अगर आपको एक मशीन इंस्टॉल करनी आई है
तो
फिर ठीक है तो
अगेन फिर से एक बार
रिक्वेस्ट तू क्योंकि आप लोग लाइक कमेंट
शेर तो करते नहीं है
[संगीत]
तो हमें तो वही है की आप फिर से अब यह
क्लास खत्म होने के बाद क्या है की दे 11
की आपकी हमारी जो डिफरेंस सिक्योरिटी का
लिंकडइन पेज है वहां पर अपडेट हो जाएगा तो
प्लीज वहां पर जाइए और जैसे आप वीडियो कर
कर लेते हैं और जैसे आप अपने नोट्स बना
लेते हैं जैसे आप जैसा भी आप कर पाते हो
तो वहां पर जाइए और कमेंट में लाइक और
कमेंट करके आप बताइए वहां पर आपको कैसा
लगा और ये हमारा ऑफिशल पेज है यहां पर आप
बताइए की आपको क्या सीखने को मिला शॉर्ट
में बता दीजिए जरा डिटेल में बताने की
जरूर की जो भी हम हमें प्रदर फॉलो करेगा
रेफर करेगा तो उसको यह पता चल जाए की हां
यहां पर कुछ एक सीरीज चली तो सीरीज में
हमने ये सीखने को मिला आप अपनी नहीं बल्कि
दूसरों की भी हेल्प कर रहे हो अब देखो
यहां पर दे 10 पे कोई कमेंट नहीं है
इसका मतलब किसी ने देखा नहीं है डेट पे तू
कमेंट्स है
एक्टिव है हमारे क्लास में स्टार्टिंग से
तो थैंक यू
बेबी
16 कमेंट है वो हर एक उसपे आना है 16 20
इतने हमारे सब्सक्राइबर 929 है लाइव में
12 आते हैं
दिल्ली की एवरेज जो मतलब की एक क्लास से
पहले
आप लोग
कुछ नहीं है कमेंट भी नहीं है ना आप हमारे
वीडियो चैनल पर कमेंट करते हैं
मोटिवेशन मिले आपके
टीचर के लिए सबसे बड़ी बात यह होती है
यानी की अगर उससे आपको सीखना तो उसको बस
क्या है कुछ ज्यादा कुछ नहीं चाहिए थे वो
आपके साथ सही होता है
और उससे ज्यादा बेस्ट कंटेंट बनाएगी जब
आपका साथ रहेगा अगर आपका साथ नहीं रहेगा
तो
क्या करेगा ना की क्लास में आएगा उसका मां
भी नहीं रहेगा क्योंकि स्टूडेंट है नहीं
है वो अकेला ही कुछ बोल रहा है तो कोई
इंटरेस्ट ले नहीं रहा है तो उसका थोड़ा
ख्याल है थोड़ा सा डिमोटिवेट होता है तो
हमारा मोटिवेशन आप लोगों से है जो
रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन देख रहे हैं वो भी सुन
लीजिए और जो हमारे साथ लाइव आते हैं उनके
लिए तो वेरी वेरी थैंक यू तो हमारा
मोटिवेशन आप लोगों से है
अगर आप लोग हमारे साथ हो तो अच्छी बात है
नहीं हो तो हमें तो डिलीवरी करना ही है आज
नहीं तो कल जिसको जरूर होगी वो तो देखेंगे
तो आगे से सेंड करते हैं
ओके तो
आयोग की सबको समझ में ए गया अगर किसी कोई
डाउट हो तो आप हमारा डाउट सेशन जो हमारा
क्या नाम है ग्रुप से
ट्विटर पर वहां जाकर आप क्या कर सकते हो
पूछ सकते हो वहां पर रिजॉल्व हो जाते हैं
आप लोगों की दूसरे लोग मुझे अच्छा लगता है
की जो दूसरे लोगों की मदद करते हैं
काफी अच्छा करता है क्योंकि हमारे पास
टाइम राहत है लेकिन आप क्या जवाब थोड़ा
वेट इसलिए करते हैं की आप अपनी प्रॉब्लम
खुद ही सॉल्व कर पाव हर बार हम नहीं रहे
हैं आपके साथ पाप का वो अपनी प्रॉब्लम खुद
ही सॉल्व करनी होगी और खुद की प्रॉब्लम
सॉल्व करने के लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
रिसर्च करना पड़ेगा तो आप रिसर्च शिवा
बनिए तो ओके अगेन सेशन और करते हैं बाय
गुड नाइट टेक केयर सी यू नेक्स्ट एक्शन